currently this is our forecast list it
looks okay but it would be nice if we
could show the degree symbol for these
temperature values using this notation
it's best practice it will help the
translator know how to reorder the text
and the parameters so that it fits the
local language now let's look at how we
can use this method to format
temperatures within our app within the
strings our XML file we declare the
format temperature string resource we
use X lift tags to denote that this is
where the decimal temperature value will
go this is followed by the Unicode
character for the degree symbol in the
utility class in the format temperature
method we can use this string resource
remember that in this method we take in
a temperature and the user's preference
for metric or imperial then we return
the converted temperature we're going to
modify this method so that it also
returns the formatted string with a
degree symbol after the value in order
to do this we need to pass in a context
from the context we can get access to
the string resource ID that we declared
earlier then we pass in any additional
parameters for that string template in
this case we only have one parameter so
we pass in the temperature value then
this fully formatted string gets
returned to the caller this method is
used in the forecast list as well as on
the detail page so we also had to update
the code there so that I would compile
with this new parameter and this is what
the app looks like after the change go
ahead and make the change in your code
to add a string resource for displaying
temperature in degrees check this box
when you're done and remember use this
notation going forward for when you need
to format strings